Everyday I look more and more insane
Right
It looks like some kind of poor moustache
Do you like it Marzia?
No?
YOU DON'T LIKE THIS?
THIS LOOKS SO GOOD
A lot of girls would die to look like this
I mean to have a boyfriend that looks like this
Today is election day
Which means that
By the time you're watching this
You know who won and became the next president
I vote for Hillary Clinton!
He always lands perfectly
*Music starts playing*
I just realised
They can see me
Anyway I'm going to the gym now
I'm in a pretty shit mood, I'm not gonna lie
I'm pretty fucking-
Annoyed
But usually me going to the gym puts me in a good mood so
Wel'll see in 3, 2, 1
Holy shit!
I feel a lot better than expected
That was a great fucking work out
What do you say Trump?
You know what, whatever happens tonight, whoever wins
This Trump
IS GONNA BURN
OH YEAH, BABY
OH MY GOD
WHERE DID IT GO?
I feel better, I shaved
Marzia: Oh you look good!
Yeah?
You don't like the moustache huh?
Marzia: I mean I have to love it
Well if you guys like the moustache you know whose fault it is
Marzia: Sorry
Marzia: I'm, the one
You should have a moustache
That's right, that's true, she is
You like this?
YOU LIKE THIS?
Marzia: No
WHAT?
Alright, now
We're going to Santa Monica
Cause Marzia
Is having a lunch meeting
But I'm coming along
And she's really happy about it
Oh my god IT'S BIRDABO
Hello BIRDA BIRDA BO
BIRDABO?
Is that sexual harassment?
Well I guess not
BYE BIRDABO
So we're gonna go to K Town now
Which is Korea Town
There's a lot of cool stuff there
I'm really excited to check it out
Uh... so let's go
Tonight, Trump will be sacrificed
Garble couldn't be more excited!
I got a package!
I wonder if... it's from crazy fans!
I DIDN'T EXPECT SUCH FAST DELIVERY
OHHH THIS IS GONNA BE PERFECT FOR TRUMP
So
You can shoot fire balls with this
That's so cool
I saw it online and I'm like I gotta buy it
You can shoot fireballs WITH. YOUR. HANDS
I gotta try that tonight
Come on
Vital
Use proper care and watch instructional video
Failure to do so may result in personal injury
EHH
LET'S GET THIS SHOW ON THE ROAD
My weed rolling skills are not the best
That's not what I'm doing I PROMISE
I DON'T SMOKE!
Alright, stand clear
CAUSE IT'S ABOUT TO POP
You ready?
Marzia: Yep!
You filming?
Marzia: Mhm hmm
WELLL
I guess I got to charge it
BRAD! Get in the car!
GET IN THE VEHICLE!
Brad: FAST AS FUCK BOY!
KEEP GOING
DAMN YOU FAST BOY!
YOU RUN REAL FAST!
Brad: You hear that? That's a sonic theme
Di do di di do di di do di DOOO DOOOO DOOOO DOOO
You're gonna run into trouble there boy!
We're in K Town
I'm told there's a lot of games here
We have no idea what we're doing
But we're the Sweds!
So they better watch out!
That's G-Dragon
He's my favourite
You wanna go
Brad: STOP
Brad: Just stop
This, this is the real shit (BLACKPINK IN YOUR AREA!)
So good
You really wanna-
You know if you want your girlfriend
You're all alone
You put on this!
She's all there
She's all that
Don't tell Marzia
Who should I win?
Michael: I think Freddy is the coolest
Come on
There you go buddy
Come on foxy
Marzia: No!
GET HIM!
GIVE ME THAT FOX
OOOHHHHHHH
MY GOD!
Not even gonna look
Not even looking
YEAHHH
Did I do it?
I DID IT
OOOHHHHHH
We both bought beyblades
And we agree that the winner
loses a strike
HERE WE GO
YOU READY TO BEYBLADE?
Michael: I'M GONNA KILL YOU MAN
I'M GONNA- MY BEYBLADE'S GONNA DESTROY YOUR BEYBLADE
Michael: OHHH NO
MY BEYBLADE'S GONNA CRUSH MY- YOUR BEYBLADE
Alright, 3, 2,
Michael: LET IT RIP!
I think I'm gonna win
Michael: GET HIM! GET HIM!
Michael: NO
COME ON BEYBLADE
COME ON GIVE IT THAT DOLLAR
WHAT ARE YOU DOING? YOU TOUCHED MINE
NO!
COME ON BEYBLADE! COME ON!
BEYBLADE BEYBLADE BEYBLADE
Michael: It touched the wall
HE NEVER STOPS SPINNING
ALL THAT MONEYYY!
And the strike
You get a strike
YOU GET A STRIKE
HELL YEAH NEXT TIME-
And we agree, that the winner loses a strike
MY BEYBLADE NEVER STOPS!
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW HOW TO ASSEMBLE A BEYBLADE
GO HOME
Are you done?
Yeah
How's that?
Good
Reminds me of when I was a kid
Fun fact, I've done an eagle
Eww
Pewds: Sponsor Eagle
Okay so, tonight is election night
No one really knows who's gonna win
So we decided that
You will lose a strike
If you just now who is gonna win
Brad: Well you gain a strike if you lose
You gain a strike if you lose?
Brad: Yeah
Alright I'm gonna go- I think Hillary is gonna win it
Brad: You vote Hillary?
Yeah
Michael: I vote Hillary too
Brad: Oh man, that means I have to go Trump
Brad: You know what, I'm losing already
Brad: No
Brad: For the record
Brad: I agree with, and would vote for Trump anyway
Brad: So I'm gonna go with Trump
Brad: GO WITH MY BOY
Brad: Now let's set him on fire!
Okay, it should work now
I'm really scared
Here we go
Michael: SHIT
You see that?
Hey Michael, you wanna shake my hand?
Michael: no
WOAHH
That was cool
TRUMP
WOAH
DAMN IT
KAME HAME....
HO
WOAH
OH SHIT
WOAH HO HO HO
WOAH
GOT EM
WOAHH
WOAH
WANNA BURN TRUMP
I WANNA BURN, TRUMP
Let us just be clear that, no matter if it's Trump or
Hillary I would still burn the pinata
Now, I didn't get the pinata
Alright, I don't care
Now
How to burn Trump
WOAHHH
DONALD TRUMP
THIS, TRUMP IS ON FIREEE
The Trump, the Trump, the Trump is on fire
We don't need no wall like the Trump
Doesn't matter who wins
As long as I don't get a strike
Who won?
Michael: Trump wins in North Carolina
Brad: MAH BOY
Brad: I'm finally invested
Brad: In a fucking American election
We've gone up for way too long
Woah
He looks insane
Look at him
He looks like Darth Vader
Wait so
Who's winning the election?
Brad: Trump
Trump is winning?
Brad: Looks like it, yeah
No
Seriously
What?
Brad: It looks like you boys are getting some strikes
He got this weird like, eyes are really close to his, inside his skull
Brad: Not a strike buddy
No
Brad: HAHA
Brad: That's a, sexy stike
UHHH
Brad: How do you feel?
One step closer to a tattoo
You hail a strike, on me
No
This can't be happening
Wait I'm so upset about it
Wait, Trump won?
I don't care, there's Toblerone here!
I'M TALKING ABOUT TOBLERONE
Stop, stop your man spreading
UHHHHH UUHHHH
That was legit terrifying from my angle
What the hell. What the fuck was that?
This cannot
Brad: DISGUSTING
Well that's another day of Birdabo
Who won the election? I don't know
We're gonna have to see
There's probably gonna be riots and shit anyway
But I hope you enjoyed another day
Sharing it with you was fun
Please leave a like if you enjoyed this episode
It really helps out a lot man really appreciate it
Share Birdabo with your friends If you think they are gonna
enjoy it and I'll see you bros
Next episode
Stay awesome bros